BACK TO YOU.
ARTHEL: THANK YOU ERIC.
ERIC: NOW TURNING TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, A FEDERAL JUDGE
IN LOUISIANA, A LEGAL CHALLENGE
TO STOP THE WHITE HOUSE FROM
ENDING TITLE 42.
BORDER RESTRICTIONS THERE, 20
STATES ARE SUPPORTING A LAWSUIT
TO KEEP TITLE 42.
THE RULE BORDER AGENTS AND
ASYLUM SEEKERS SENT BACK TO
MEXICO BECAUSE OF THE COVID
PANDEMIC.
YOU'RE LOOKING LIVE IN EAGLE
PASS TEXAS WHERE BILL MELUGIN IS
AT THE BORDER WITH THE LATEST ON
THE NEWEST CROSSINGS.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, I CAN TELL
YOU ILLEGAL CROSSINGS ARE
NONSTOP HERE AND THAT IS WITH
TITLE 42 STILL IN PLACE AND WE
WILL SHOW YOU THAT.
LOOK AT THIS VIDEO WE SHOT HERE
THIS MORNING WHEN WE HAD ANOTHER
MASSIVE SINGLE GROUP OF WELL
UNDER 100 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
CROSSING, THIS IS THE FOURTH DAY
IN A ROW WE'VE SEEN BIG GROUPS
OF MORE THAN 100, EVERYDAY FOR
THE LAST FOUR DAYS AROUND 11:00
IN THE MORNING, WE SEE BIG
GROUPS CROSSING LIKE CLOCKWORK.
WE SAW A CARTEL SCOUT ON THE
OTHER SIDE TAKING A PEEK AT THE
RIVER BEFORE THE GROUP CAME
ACROSS, 30 MINUTES LATER BUT
THIS WASN'T THE ONLY GROUP.
WE SEE THIS EVERY DAY, LOOK AT
THIS VIDEO, WE SAW THIS GROUP OF
150 ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS CROSSING
FRIDAY, SAME THING, SAME
LOCATION, SAME TIME IN THE
MORNING, MOST OF THESE MIGRANT
CROSSING HAVE BEEN FROM
COLUMBIA, VENEZUELA AND CUBA AND
BORDER PATROL REPORTED IN THE
LAST WEEK THEY'VE HAD MORE THAN
EIGHT OF THESE SINGLE MASSIVE
GROUPS CROSSING IN EAGLE PASS, A
HUGE STRAIN ON BORDER PATROL
RESOURCES.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE MANPOWER TO
PROCESS, THEY HAVE TO CALL IN
AGENTS FROM ELSEWHERE AND SAY IT
LIKE A BROKEN RECORD BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO SAY, GAPS ALONG THE
BORDER WHERE CARTEL CAN PUSH
DRUGS AND RUNNERS THROUGH.
THE MAYOR PRO TEM EAGLE PASS NOT
HAVING WAS GOING ON, SHE WANT TO
TITLE 42 TO STAY IN PLACE AND
SHE SAYS IS CAUSING TOO MANY
ISSUES FOR THEIR CITY.
>> AS A COUNCILPERSON WE GET
PHONE CALLS, WHAT ARE WE GOING
TO DO ABOUT THESE PEOPLE, WHAT
ARE YOU DOING ABOUT THE PEOPLE
STAYING HERE?
WE DON'T DO THAT, WE DO LOCAL
BUSINESS, THIS IS FEDERAL.
>> THIS AFTERNOON WE LEARNED OF
UNPRECEDENTED DEAL, THE RACE
BETWEEN THE STATE OF TEXAS AND
MEXICAN STATE LAST NIGHT, THE
STATE ACROSS FROM EAGLE PASS, WE
ARE TOLD THE STATE OF TEXAS WILL
PROVIDE RAZOR WIRE TO MEXICAN
AUTHORITIES TO BEEF UP BORDER
SECURITY ON THEIR SIDE OF THE
BORDER.
MEXICANS ARE COMING TO EAGLE
PASS IN THE COMING DAYS, TEXAS
NATIONAL GUARD WILL TRAIN THEM
HOW TO DEPLOY THEM AND TAKE
POSSESSION AND GO BACK TO MEXICO
AND START CONSTRUCTING IT ALONG
THEIR BORDER.
THIS IS THE F